matthieu delormeau il rêve de présenter
une émission sur s'est vite mais tout le
monde a envie qu'il se fasse virer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ainsi que le studio daniel et de la
captivante avec moi
un animateur de talent benjamin castaldi
mais son legs de tpm p la chroniqueuse
l'amour entière
quelqu'un avec une croix à moitié ses
phrases jean michel maire
pis elle est amoureuse de lui mais moi à
cet enjeu plus d'amoureuse que toi marie
gillain émaillé la légende du tpn
oui
je bats je présente les misseriya je
fais quoi moi tu m'avais dit quand on va
partir en retraite je vais prendre ta
place à son adjoint d'alors mozy
matthieu delormeau
il rêve de présenter une émission sur
s'est vite mais tout le monde a envie
qu'il se fasse virer
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
la plus drôle isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
la police dans tpm p 6 ouais il faudrait
qu'on applaudisse merci mon chéri
d'avoir été avec une sextape trouve ta
maison tu vas nous faire un petit bisou
accueilli oui merci merci au jury
d'abord été bien de l'équipe avec avec
ma tata est ma maman je suis fais là
[Applaudissements]
la merci mon chéri d'amour auquel bon
pour la planète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]